hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my game of thrones season 7
villains video we're going to talk about
the biggest baddest best villain so of
course boilers from everything that's
happened on the show so far so mostly
you know that game of thrones doesn't
really have straight up villains it has
a lot of antagonists antagonist is a
better word but you know for the
purposes of this video is just easier to
call them villains the people that the
subtext is telling you to root against
like everybody always loves Cersei
because Lena Headey is so amazing but
she is most definitely one of the
biggest villains to come out of the end
of season six so you know just right off
the bat i will say she's probably gonna
be my favorite villain of season 7 even
though she's written in such a complex
way that you can identify with why she's
doing things but it is certain point you
do have to say like okay she is
definitely the villain of this Daenerys
vs Cersei storyline that's gonna be
happening in the crown lands because of
all the atrocities that she is committed
now the nearest has killed a lot of
people but she's also freed a lot of
slave so you know like you kind of have
to balance out the bad things she does
with the good things that she does in
her intentions
what is it exactly that Cersei is
fighting for like she killed a bunch of
her own subjects she wasn't killing
enemies of the kingdom she was killing
people that were trying to kill her like
so she was defending her own life she
was being very selfish and as a
consequence of that Tommen ended up
dying
dan and dave clarified that the subtext
to that whole event was you know the
Tommen was just like going crazy in his
head and probably needed his mother to
lead him through that but then the
realization that his mother was
responsible for this and no one was
there to be with him to help him just
was too much for him so he's just like I
can't handle this i'm out peace so the
counterpoint to that is actually when
Cersei was still you know bad person but
not really an antagonist was the
Blackwater episode where she's sitting
there with Tommen clutching him
thinking that if they lose the battle
Stannis takes the red key she's going to
commit assisted suicide with her and
Tommen so that they can't be taken alive
so that's a very bad Cersei sympathetic
moment but you know where she's swirling
her wine here in where she walks out on
shame nun like if it wasn't clear what
she blows up the great set you know
because everyone was kind of cheering
when that happened because it was so
amazing looking
the real Cersei villain moment of the
season was when she left
Shame nun with the mountain knowing full
well what was going to happen
oh no you're not going to die today so
it is totally ok to root for Cersei just
because Lena Headey is so amazing as
long as you remember that she is
probably the bad person in this fight
with daenerys the actual battle for
the Iron Throne even jamie is
questioning his loyalty to Cersei now
like oh my god i have no idea when i'm
going to just look on his face here is
priceless
so when all the storylines that are
going to be happening in season 7 just
remember that idea they'll be like
fantastic actors but there will
definitely be an antagonist for each
storyline so like up in the North
they've been teasing jon snow versus Sansa
maybe the you know nothing part of jon
snow doesn't realize what's going on
inside Sansa's head how she feels a little
slighted by all the stuff that's
happened in how she might act out as a
result of that in what little finger
might do to take advantage of it
so while Sansa might seem like the
antagonist really little finger is going
to be the actual villain of that
northern storyline just because he's
going to create as much chaos as
possible
chaos is a ladder it all goes back to
that amazing little finger speech but
slightly lesser storylines they'll
probably be some barriers for Samwell
across like you don't just automatically
have access to everything that he needs
at the Citadel the arch maesters have a
very strong opinion about the way they
go about their business in Samwell is
trying to become a maester so he has to
follow their rules and if it wasn't
clear from like the really funny
exchange that he had with that person
when he was entering the citadel that's
only the beginning he's probably going
to have a much harder time I just I'm
not expecting the season to give us too
many Samwell scenes because there's only
going to be about seven episodes which
means the story will be less sprawling
which is actually a good thing but bad
and it will have to like cut down on
some other storylines like Samwell at the
citadel so a lot of you are also asking
what about the White Walkers won't they
be some of the biggest villains of the
season
well the funny thing is the way Dan and
Dave talk about them like they're like
well they represent death in the
narrative we don't think of them as
traditional villains so you can kind of
understand where they're coming from
like the White Walkers are a force of
nature like literally a force of nature
force created by those who worship
nature so they're kind of more of an
ethereal threat and that's actually the
way they've been using them in the story
I
you don't think they'll be actually like
physical antagonist where you have a big
battle till the final season so what I
still kind of do think of them as
villains I don't think they're gonna be
villains in the sense that Cersei is a
villain of season seven so they'll be
there but they're like the ticking clock
down like they're just there to remind
you that death is slowly marching on it
cannot be stopped the really fun part
that i haven't mentioned that you're
probably wondering about is what about
euron I think he's gonna be the
surprise bitches Ramsey villain of
season 7 like you thought you forgot
about me but I'm actually a really
terrible person with a pretty large
force my back so I think in the way that
Ramsey went from being just like an
awful person in a dungeon to being this
really big antagonist I think that
you're on will turn from this person who
seems like a threat into a much bigger
threat in season 7 like if he lines with
anyone it will probably be Cersei
because right now the entire kingdom
hates or even the people in King's
Landing look like they're going to turn
on her so she is going to seek allies
wherever she can find them in right now
the greatest thing that Euron could
do for Cersei is help make sure that she
still has a steady supply of food coming
into the city because the Tyrells they
basically control most of the food in
the kingdom is because so much of it is
grown on their lands so if she wants to
the queen of thorns could totally
starved Cersei out so she's going to
need to get food somehow Euron is
just one of the many ways that she could
solve that problem but i know i haven't
talked much about the East there i mean
there's still a lot of big forces in the
East but I think the show has largely
come back to Westeros so most of the
storylines you see will take place in
the Seven Kingdoms like I said one of
the benefits of the story being fewer
episodes as bad as that sounds
is that the story will be less sprawling
so I'm not expecting us to visit the
east a whole lot but let me know in the
comments
who's your favorite antagonist going
into season 7 like who do you think is
going to be the biggest baddest best
villain right now I still think that
it's going to be Cersei just because
Lena Headey so fantastic so they write
her that way they write her to be this
amazing villain but i just love the idea
that Daenerys is moving in with her for
like she has this amazing large force
that she's going to bring in to lay
siege to King's Landing and it looks
like Cersei's own subjects are going to
turn on her especially Jamie even the
Lena Headey
he is probably signed a contract that's
going to take her through season a so I
think they're gonna try and keep her
around as long as possible but that
doesn't necessarily mean that she's
still going to be sitting on the Iron
Throne in season eight in related
awesome news there is a new round of the
giveaway that starts now is just a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video if
there are any game of Thrones bonus
videos that you guys want this week just
let me know in the comments
there's not a whole lot of news
happening right now but I'm expecting a
few surprises for winter winter in the
books and stuff like that but if you
guys didn't know george RR martin did
land another TV series but it's going to
be at FX it's for his wild card series
that has absolutely nothing to do with
Game of Thrones but there will be
another george RR martin big epic series
that they try to develop for television
so high fives to Martin his stuff is
blowing up like wildfire right now while
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my season 7
teaser trailer breakdown and you can
click here for all my season 7
predictions
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five i'll see you guys
tonight